Let's summarize what we've learned about
the Chain Matrix Multiplication problem.
There is an algorithm which,
given the dimensions of n matrices,
finds an expression tree that computes
the product with the minimum number of
multiplications in order
n to he cubed time.
Recall that there were order
n entries in the table, and
we spend order n time figuring out
what value to write in each one.
The optimal similar
substructure that we exploited
was the minimum cost of
evaluating the subchains.
The key recurrence said that
the cost of each partition
was the minimum cost of computing the
left subtree plus the minimum cost of
computing the right subtree,
plus the cost of combining them.
And of course, we want to take
the minimum over all such partitions.